What do you think, David?
>> So perhaps unsurprisingly,
I said that the two most similar
situations in my original answer were
both deeply and superficially similar.
A woman climbing a step ladder
is both deeply similar in that
the relationship are the same.
And superficially similar
in that the woman and
the ladder are somewhat similar.
I also said that the woman climbing
a set of stairs is both deep and
superficially similar.
We still have a woman climbing in both,
and
I said that a set of stairs is somewhat
superficially similar to a ladder,
in that both are designed
to allow someone to ascend.
Although some others might say that
that's not superficially similar.
Then I said that the other three that
involved rising in some way were all
deeply similar as well.
The plane taking off into the sky,
the woman climbing the corporate ladder,
and the ant walking up the wall were all
deeply similar to me because all
involved this relationship of climbing.
I said that the woman painting a ladder
was only superficially similar,
which is why it was one of the lowest
rated in our original exercise.
And finally the water bottle sitting
on a desk is neither deeply similar nor
superficially similar,
because nothing is the same
between those two situations.
>> This is good, David.
Once again, different people may give
different answers to this exercise.
Why did we do so?
Well, let's examine it next.